Alex Jacker
budget Dave a big moment for the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt and for Rishi
sunak his first as prime minister it
will set the tone for his Premiership
and could even decide the next election
we were expecting big announcements on
Child Care pensions and the energy price
cap and we got them the family's feeling
the pinch fuel Duty Frozen beer Duty cut
energy bills capped and for parents 30
hours of free child care for all under
fives today we build for the future
I'm Liz Bates and on today's Sky News
Daily I'm in Westminster bringing you
all the analysis and reaction you need
so lots of things were announced in the
hour-long budget but there were four big
ones free child care for working parents
of young children I don't want any
parent with a child under five to be
prevented from working if they want to
because it's damaging to our economy and
unfair mainly to women so today I
announce that ineligible households
where all adults are working at least 16
hours we will introduce 30 hours of free
child care not just for three and
four-year-olds but for every single
child over the age of nine months an
extension of the energy price cap I
today confirm that the energy price
guarantee will remain at two and a half
thousand pounds for the next three
months tax cuts on pensions no one
should be pushed out of the workforce
for tax reasons so today I will increase
the pension's annual tax-free allowance
from by 50 percent from forty thousand
to sixty thousand
some have also asked me to increase the
lifetime allowance from its one million
pound limit
but I've decided not to do that instead
I will go further and abolish the
lifetime allowance and tax breaks for
businesses that means that every single
pound a company invests in it equipment
plant or Machinery can be deducted in
full and immediately from taxable
profits
and we're joined Now by our political
editor Beth Rigby and our economics and
data editor Ed Conway hello to both of
you hello hi so nice to have you here
you've already done hours and hours of
talking and dissecting the budget you
were still tapping away on your laptop a
second ago Beth we had to stop you this
is how much analysis is going on I'm so
happy to have you both here to dissect
the budget
so let's start with what seems to be one
of the flagship policies child care so
we had a pretty good idea that that was
coming there's already though been
criticism of it because clearly it's
very appealing to extend three hours of
child care to children now from nine
months all the way up until four in
England but Beth look the criticism
already was that it may not actually
work in practice at those places just
simply won't be available there'll be
too much pressure on the sector having
seen the detail of it today what do you
make of it I think that's the issue Liz
because
on the one hand in the big broad brush
of it this is a part of the welfare
state that hasn't really worked or been
fixed like why is it that kids going to
school at five but there's no wrap
around provision and there's not any
support for when you are really strained
with the cost of child care so you know
it's a massive outlier yeah
but in terms of the concerns around it
are they putting enough money in
basically so you know it's a massive
expansion a massive expansive policy so
we thought they were going to do one to
two year olds and he extended it
actually down to nine months onwards but
is it going to be enough money to
actually pay the providers for the
places I.E you make the policy but does
it deliver and then the other question I
guess for parents is the way in which
it's staggered because it it doesn't
actually come into effect for for many
kids until after uh the next general
elections about so some parents
potentially quite disappointed by The
Staggering aspect of it yeah because you
you know you you've got to start now
haven't you having children like
tomorrow how does that work you've
already got three though so you're not
having anything yet well maybe there's
changes there
people you can underplay the extent to
which tax incentives have an impact on
things like this but they do I do want
to get onto the other uh the other big
announcement today again we knew it was
coming on pensions uh ads
um first of all can you just explained
we knew some of it was coming like we
knew they were going to raise the
lifetime allowance but we didn't know
they were going to abolish it basically
wow moment in the studio
but I mean on the face of it you know
it's really quite a big deal because it
means it removes that kind of cap on how
much you can put into your pension pot
over your lifetime but you've got to
bear in mind there is still a limit on
how much you can put in each year so
that's gone up but it's still nowhere
near what it was for instance when
Gordon Brown was Chancellor so in the
scheme of things
well that is that's still a big thing
that the government is taxing now that
it wasn't a few years ago but it's
taxing it a bit less than before the the
economic argument and everything's here
supposed to come back to the fact that
they want to get more people into work
okay you've got a lot of people
pensioners in particular they might have
got enough in their pension pot they
might have hit that kind of one million
limit and thought well why would I
bother working more it's not as kind of
tax efficient and it might well persuade
some of them to get back into work and
the idea is so we talked about child
care that's at the kind of lower end so
it's a younger workers potentially
getting back into the workforce after
having had children a bit sooner and
then in the upper end you've got
pensioners potentially getting back into
the workforce and put all of that
together and the idea is economic
inactivity has gone up a lot since the
pandemic higher than in almost every
other country around the world part of
its long-term sector part of it's this
this issue it should help on that fronts
and so there is a coherence there I
think the issue is that it's it's all
still a little bit fiddly and this is
all this is primarily this pension thing
is probably primarily money that's going
to benefit better off people it's not
not the Super Rich but definitely the
rich labor will kind of quick out for
the traps with this because you know as
soon as it landed I'm getting messages
from them saying it's only going to
benefit the one percent of the
population with the biggest pension
Parts Only 8 600 people exceeded the
lifetime allowance in 2020 to 21 the
lifetime like I you've you've
accumulated one million quid in your
pension pot
I I so my Spidey Sense tells me that
becomes quite a contentious thing yeah
if you wanted if you wanted to find a
line of attack in this budget the one
thing you know how it can be in budgets
that it all looks totally great and then
something blows up and it only starts
really unraveling I think this is the
thing that could I I think I think that
giving a massive bung to people with
pension pots above a million quid I
understand why they do doing it the
argument is
that particularly with NHS professionals
and doctors and surgeons in their 50s
very wealthy you know worked hard all
their lives they get really well paid
they get to their 50s and they think
like I'm kind of being taxed heavily
because I can't offset any of my tax for
my pension fund I've got a massive
pension pot I'm just going to step out
of the workforce so that there is a
clearing there's a clear reason to do it
and I guess the argument there is these
are very in terms of the economy more
broadly these are very economically
valuable people yeah you know they have
huge amount of expertise and experience
they're people that we desperately need
to be bringing back into the economy I
mean that's it isn't it it's because it
is the part of I guess the argument is
this may not necessarily be very
politically popular but if it boosts
growth then that's that's a good thing
and that kind of you know is the same
argument I guess with probably the
biggest giveaway of all which was the um
full expensing the name of it is so
uncatchy that I could not remember it
and I couldn't even find I don't think I
tell you it's really exciting you can
yeah so okay so you remember there was
this the super deduction okay that was
that's got a slightly better name it's
got a better name I reckon this might be
more Super than the super deduction okay
I reckon it might be more Super remember
Corporation taxes going up yeah a lot
okay super deduction was kind of about
making sure that there was gonna be it
wasn't going to be people pulling money
out this is different and I think like
if you talk to any business right now
and you know I talk to a lot of them
this was the thing they've been calling
for for ages and it basically means that
if you're buying a big bit of Machinery
you can basically offset 100 of that
against your future profits which means
you're incentivized to do it you're
going out you're spending more on
factories you're spending more equipment
you're spending more on all of this
stuff that theoretically is good for the
economy and right now we're at this
point where we we are heading into what
might be a new Industrial Revolution
you've got the green energy transition
happening right now it's big stuff and
it needs big Investments So in theory
this encourages companies to do more of
that like the question is it is
technically temporary everyone thinks it
should be renewed but technically it's
temporary and if you look at the numbers
in the document I don't know how much I
buy them but the numbers in the document
suggest that it won't actually boost
investment at all it'll just kind of
Bring It Forward a bit and I guess we
have to see whether that actually proves
to be the case so if we take a step back
here what was Jeremy Hunt really trying
to achieve with this budget if we sort
of zoom out onto these two big policies
we've talked about in detail but why do
they matter it's because these are two
areas getting people back into work and
getting companies to invest mix it all
together Stir It Around what do you
hopefully get if you're Jeremy Hunt you
get growth and and that's what this is
about it's about trying to get more
growth into the economy to try and make
people feel going into the next general
election which we think will probably be
in the Autumn of 2024 at the moment that
their lives are finally getting better
after some really difficult years of
squeeze but if you look at it also in
the round in the right here and now
as I said the reality of people's lives
of fall in household incomes and they
are now going to be hit by more of them
being pulled into higher tax bands
because the government have Frozen all
the tax plan so you get this fiscal drag
where more people just get pulled into
higher bands as their wages go up people
are going to notice that and people are
not people are going to probably not
feel that great in terms of how they're
doing in the next coming months I think
the gamble for the conservatives in fact
I don't think it's a gamble I think it's
the only option they've got in fact I've
got a quote from a key Ally of the PM
they said it's got to be a growth budget
we're fighting to be competitive again
with labor if we can get to next summer
and the economy is ticking up and we can
narrow the Gap in the polls to five
eight points there's a chance in an
election campaign we can shift the dial
so that's the strategy so you can get
growth next year you can Tinker around a
bit can you give a big tax giveaway
going into an election and people then
feel like their lives are working under
you you know on the economy half
inflation tick the economy is going to
be growing again this year tick he's
already done two of them they weren't
especially ambitious
no that was the bank of England forecast
but the point was it's like I'm going to
only promise what I can do after kind of
Voters have become rather disillusioned
by previous Prime Ministers who have
promised and not delivered right so what
this is is I think to me the way I read
it Ed was this is a chancellor saying I
had a plan I'm delivering on my plan we
are now trusted on the economy we are a
party of sound uh fiscal and economic
management please ignore his trust stick
with us and then I'm going to give you
some tax breaks and I'm going to make
this a very retail budget in 2024 right
no I think that's I think that's it and
I but I mean I think that the issue like
you said is
there's two things they're fighting the
first is the scale of what's happening
to households disposable income it's
like you know numbers don't lie and that
is going to be Grim this year and next
are going to feel really horrible for
for many households around the country
thanks to inflation but also thanks to
the fact that their taxes like you said
this is going on taxes are going up so
you're going to notice it on your tax
bill and you're going to notice it on
your shopping bill as well so fighting
that on the one hand and then on the
other hand
the the legacy of what happened last
Autumn and whether they can turn around
the credibility loss that they suffered
there do people think oh I'm wanting to
give them another go or do they just
think well their credibility is short
after what happened with markets
[Music]
okay so Ed Beth let's take this out of
Westminster and look at this from the
perspective of just a normal person a
voter out there in the country
struggling with the cost of living
stagnant wages struggling to get into
work today because there are strikes
across the country and then the
government gives us this budget talking
about inflation and growth targets tax
cuts for businesses and Wealthy
pensioners does it all feel just really
out of touch you know when we talk about
I've just gone back to it because the
ABR on the stealth taxes drag in nearly
6 million people into higher tax spans
over the next four years juxtapose that
with there's some help on energy bills
you'll you know the price of the pump
won't go up you know you've frozen beer
Duty and obviously the child care for
like and I know I had I mean I've got
two kids and one you're all trying to
pay child care costs is excruciating is
but how do you basically make people
feel better off it's vat National
Insurance and income that's what's going
to come I mean that the retail the
retail and that comes but it has to come
right this is the gamble because he has
uh it seems like the approach is let's
try to do the right thing to hit our
economic targets and then people will
feel better off but there's no there's
no showboating here there's no policies
to to just make people feel better off
instantly so that's the big gamble
it's the type it's also it's just the
timing of the cycle right if you're the
chancellor you you'll cut you want to
avoid recession you want to get the
economy growing you've got an Autumn
statement uh in November next this year
and then you've got a budget in March
you've got two big fiscal events there
to then pitch roll uh through for the
general election can I ask you about the
politics of all this because the
conservatives are still doing badly in
the polls which she's you know staying a
little bit better is that anything in
this budget that makes you think this
could shift the dial I think it matters
that a lot of the coverage over the last
kind of six months or even just last
three months has been the UK is uniquely
badly situated right now we're doing
terribly everyone else is doing better I
think that will turn around and the fact
that when this is the beginning of that
starting to turn around because I don't
think we were quite as bad as all that I
think the IMF forecasts were a little
bit too much so I think that might help
a little bit you know in terms of people
feeling that we're less of a basket case
frankly the way I look at it is in the
round of broader kind of what's the
government approach and the budget is I
I called I described as the third act I
think the other day in what the prime
minister's been trying to do since
certainly the beginning of February and
that was number one I'm going to try and
rehabilitate the UK on the world stage
so you've seen him off in you know the
US with Biden and doing that submarine
deal you then of course had the northern
Ivan protocol deal now that was all
about trying to resolve the row with the
European Union over post-brexit trading
Arrangements in Northern Ireland right
so there's this and this is the show not
tell policies like I'm just going to do
this stuff and then people are going to
see me doing this and then they're going
to think a grown-up is running the party
and Mr sensible is back and it's
politics as normal and it's all going to
be a bit boring but actually people
maybe want boring so you've had that
sort of diplomatic sort of
Rehabilitation and then secondly you
have the small boats announcement now as
I said listen this is not small boats
podcast it's budget podcast but there's
so many issues around that policy in
Practical terms about returns agreements
legally uh whether it will work but what
the Prime Minister can at least do going
into a general election is say well I
tried to do it and I was thwarted by the
French or the European Union I was
thwarted by the courts but already I
think that his polling ratings are
improving on the back of that policy
because it speaks to a particular group
of Voters that have either deserted the
Tories or are thinking about about
deserting the Tories right so he's done
that and then you know act three today
the studies she goes budget and what
that dude is saying we are the party of
sound economic management so this is all
basically part of a bigger political
plan the the three acts have been the
kind of covered off the fire the pledges
you made at the beginning of the year I
think what we're going to see later in
the year is now now I've proved to you
that I can handle things here's some
Vision then then it will be kind of like
decontaminate the brand show that I am
competent and then try and convince you
why you should look at me again and
maybe give me another chance uh and and
vote for me I have to say that and Liz I
did a focus group in Wickham last week
which is it's always been a conservative
seat since the 1950s we had floating
voters uh the group had voted a mix of
conservative labor and lib Dem in the
last election
and they really really really were fed
up of the government like properly fed
up yeah they were frustrated about the
cost of living they were anxious they
didn't see it getting better when I
asked this group who thinks that this
country needs to change everyone put
their hand up but on the chance there
for Rishi sunak is that then when we
asked them about starma they're like we
don't know what this guy's about we're
not convinced about him we want change
but he's no Tony Blair so you know if
you're you know in cchq listen to that
sort of thing you like there's a chance
there's a chance so it's an opportunity
there no question and also I mean you
have to look at you know kirst armor for
such a long time just completely
occupied that territory of maybe he
seems quite boring but he also seems
quite competent and now suddenly we have
Rishi sunak potentially a little bit
boring but certainly coming across as
competence does he have time to turn it
around I suppose to the question can I
ask you guys uh just uh maybe one of the
final questions was it a bit boring and
is that a good thing this was the first
kind of normalish budget that we've had
in quite a long time wasn't it yeah
because if you think about it we you
know we have covered and that really
wasn't like normal budgets you were
having kind of policy on the hoof and
actually some of the biggest decisions
weren't happening in budgets so this is
actually the first kind of normal
inverted Commerce budget that we've had
in quite a long time so it does it might
feel a little bit boring but there was
quite a lot of stuff in there and the
economic story is getting a little bit
better than it looked before for markets
oh listen on markets okay that actually
the real story here is that no one cares
about what's happening here that things
are going down and it's not looking good
in a lot of markets around the world
everyone's worried about Banks you had
those Bank collapses in America that
obviously the UK branch that collapsed
as well in Switzerland right now Credit
Suisse one of the biggest banks in the
world is looking in deep deep trouble
and as a result of that markets up
markets are going south but not because
of the UK but the the kind of benign
sequence of that is it might be in our
interest rates are a little bit lower
because everyone's panicking a bit so
they don't think rates are going to go
up so how much but yeah this didn't
shock the markets but it is against the
backdrop of markets being pretty
stressed and can I ask you just both
very briefly number 10 will be thinking
of course about how this all plays out
in the long term but their eye for today
will be on how it lands in the
newspapers what's going to be the big
thing that is on the front of tomorrow's
newspaper so so after you'll know this
list because you've been to them now one
of the sad things about being a
broadcaster not a print journalist
because I used to be a print journalist
is that after a budget you have what's
known as the Huddle and the huddlers
when all the journalists send in on this
room just outside uh where we go we're
going to Commons and basically everyone
gets the red book and then we all race
to what the score card I know you're
like what is she talking about the score
card is the bit in the middle of the
budget statement but the big red book
and it basically costs all the policies
what's this I love you can you can read
a budget from a school card and often
what happens is the chancellor gives the
rhetoric of the budget and he really
sells it wants to sell and then the
journalists take the scorecard and they
deconstruct now I can't sat like this is
one of my favorite things to do go and
sadly because I'm on the actual Telly
box sort of instantly reacting with Ed I
don't get to go to the Huddle but
certainly the messages coming out from
the Huddle from my uh secret sources uh
told me that the issue that was
agitating journalists which I was not
surprised about at all is the issue
around the tax break for the big pension
pots which given as I said what happened
in the last budget with the 45 Pence tax
cut and you can sort of see some of the
left leaning papers that is such an easy
attack line for them you know so I want
I wonder whether that would be tricky
but I mean if you wanted a positive
headline for a Chancellor I mean to be
able to say we've we're avoiding a
technical recession this this year you
know it doesn't get better than that
really and then child care I think the
thing is also the problem is is I think
Child Care was the rabbit in the Hat and
the guardian did some brilliant digging
and sort of extracted the rabbit from
the rabbit hole the whole thing and and
basically that sort of blew the rabbit
out of the water so part of the problem
as well is that when you're planning
these things in the treasury you go
right what we do is we'll we'll travel
that and we'll do that we'll do that and
then you know there's the surprise and
then that's the headlines but that was
the headlines for last night so now
everyone's got to find something else
and the the most for me today I don't
know about you had the most arresting
thing in that moment was when he said
well I'm not just lifting the lifetime
allowance on petrol I'm scrapping it all
together and I looked at and went wow I
wasn't expecting that so so
you know and if I'm wrong don't hold it
against me we'll just cut it out of the
podcast yeah yeah just edit it out so
editing's for it I just want to say
thank you both so so much it's been a
pleasure it's been it's been fun and we
can't wait when when's the next one
November awesome statement tomorrow
thank you
my thanks to Beth and Ed and to you for
listening to the Sky News Daily with me
Liz Bates this episode was produced by
Rosie Gillett our editor is Philly
Beaumont